Garth Brooks
what happened oh yeah I saw this Garth
Brooks is is he's gonna have Bud Light
at his bar Tommy yeah he's not gonna
he's refusing to ban it was
yeah wow information is right down here
I know it sounds corny I want it to be
the Chick-fil-A of Honky Tonks about his
new bar
um in Nashville I want it to be a place
you feel safe in I want it to be a place
where you feel like there are manners
and people like one another hmm
and he added something there
and yes we're going sorry go down if you
go down he says and yes we're going to
serve every brand of beer we just are
it's not our decision to make well yeah
it is your decision to make yeah our
thing is this if you are into this house
love one another
if you're an [__] there are plenty of
other places on Lower Broadway oh wow
shots fired kind of yeah and there it is
Dylan Mulvaney they're gonna get in
there do you want to hear something that
I just heard yeah so I've talked about
him quite a bit about Garth Brooks I
know you guys have had some issues and I
found out this is dude I found out first
I got word
about a year ago
from like of like a hundred percent
reliable source it sounds seems good
um that um I was like does he know and
they're like oh yeah yeah he knows
and I was like is he upset and they're
like he's just like doesn't get it like
doesn't know why you're talking about
him
I was like okay and then recently I
guess uh so he just blocked me on
Instagram oh
um and I was like uh I was finally
finally blocked me you know uh and then
the person another person told me to go
yeah I heard
this person said to me that they heard
from a reliable source that when my name
comes up to him
that he on his phone shows the video of
me playing basketball and falling and
goes Karma
no Karma yeah
and I was like that's [__] pretty
amazing wow that a serial killer is
finding it in their heart to say karma
for the other person like this man has
I mean people are saying this man is
responsible for hundreds of missing
people and he's gonna
would say that it's karma well yes
somebody matched up I saw something
where they matched up like his tour
dates with missing people that's the
whole like that's the premise of this
idea like people are like saying that
I'm you know like trolling the guy all
I'm doing is repeating what I've heard
that allegedly
his tour schedule aligns with like
dozens of missing persons yeah and so oh
well I mean it's just something that
like at least you would bring up and
talk it's like why do people talk about
UFOs you know why do why why have the
conversation about something in the like
well because people are saying that that
could be
a visitor from another planet right are
we not going to have even a conversation
about it right if if
75 people are missing and there's an all
in cities that like he has just been in
I mean it's it's logical to say well
okay and look at him there you telling
me I'm not you tell me you've done
anything but that's the the the smile
and the stare of a guy who has never
done anything
illegal I don't know and how much land
he has too so much land
you wouldn't even know somebody who's
missing or if you'd put somebody
somewhere or not so much land he's the
Easter Bunny of bodies kind of oh yeah
and he's so here's the thing it's the
perfect you're so beloved that like oh
yeah we mentioned the authorities too
they'd be like I'm sorry we were this is
crazy but we actually had a a dog that
can smell you know uh the corpse and it
was on your property and it just went
crazy and then he'd be like I don't I'm
Garth Brooks yeah they're like yeah
you're right you're right sorry we're
gonna head on out yeah yeah we're
thinking we signed this for my son yeah
exactly my dog the dog actually had a
seizure on your property
never had a smell like that in its life
but uh my son actually went missing on
your property in case he comes back will
you sign this behind this guitar yeah
appreciate you g
Onna hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one